[Music]
how do you
wrap your head around or maybe it's not
maybe it's pretty simple
and it's there's a lot of drama a lot of
noise but the signals are staying the
same
that um i try to keep up with the stuff
so i stay right so i know what's
happening
um how do you do that yeah so so here's
what i do and this is what i love
so much about what you do and dave and
friends of ours like ken coleman is
it's all about principles there are
principles that stay the same
from the beginning of time till the end
of time and when you are anchored to
those core principles
you don't have to read every single
study out there you can read some and i
keep up on things but
it's not this it's not that's not my
anchor the the new
research that comes out today is not my
anchor these principles that are talked
about in places like the bible
those are my core principles that i live
by and so i'll give an example
you know this is there were studies that
have
came out many years ago and still not
recently to where
there were companies that were
pharmaceutical based that owned
uh infant formula companies to where
they started coming out with this
research saying
breast milk is not ideal for kids right
because it's high i'm not kidding no i
know they i know they are
yeah and so they started coming out with
these studies saying yeah breast milk is
not what's ideal for kids they're better
off with formula breast milk is not as
high in these certain vitamins and we
put these in there
but like we know that god created breast
milk to be the perfect
food for an infant and so
i'm just saying that to say this is that
we've got to understand a lot of these
big agricultural companies
pharmaceutical companies a lot of these
big fight even financial institutions
whatever it is
a lot of times there's the there's
agendas tied to them we're talking about
trillion dollar industries here
so i think it's important to consider
that but for me you know i was on a
health panel with another
very prominent uh very prominent medical
doctor
and we were they asked a question
exactly almost what you asked i said hey
with all the new research coming out how
do i decide what to eat and his answer
was
you decide based on whatever the
research just says as
of today so hey if it says today you
should be eating
apples eat apples if tomorrow says
apples are bad then stop eating apples
and i was literally my mind was blown
because i thought this is the way
literally a lot of people think about
this and for me it's like listen
bone broth has been consumed from the
beginning of time you know we have the
story in the
bible where you know jacob and esau are
like you know making soup
and you know we know that we've made
bone broth for a long time people have
consumed it they consume it in
asia today in south america across the
world it's been a
a meal to help boost and support immune
health
so all that being said number one is i
anchor and understand these core
principles
and then i use this latest studies
to help to help educate and reinforce
exactly what uh how things work today
so i've i've noticed i love that you
said that i've noticed an arc
for the last 20 years and
about 10 years ago i was at a uh at
with a buddy and we were having dinner
and he was in the nutrition space and he
said hey
you know what's really freaking
everybody out on the front edge of all
this stuff
i said what he said that the data's
starting to come back pretty clear
if you eat whole foods and you have good
relationships and
you believe in something bigger than
yourself you're probably gonna be okay
most of the time oh yeah outside of an
acute
injury or some you know weird thing and
um that the arc of a lot of this
cutting-edge
banana research we're spending
bajillions of dollars on fmri all these
studies
are leading us back to and slow down
take care of your relationships eat
whole foods that's right and take care
of yourself
there's an old sam tele quote that if
it's not
in nature if if you see something in
nature and you think you've just figured
out a new thing you're probably wrong
yeah right and i love that um that that
sentiment
nature's had a long time to work on well
and i want to give example how
wise some of these different sort of uh
you know ancient physicians were you
know there was a study that came out
about 10 years ago on tumeric
and if you consume the [ __ ] there's a
compound in turmeric curcumin right
which has all these anti-inflammatory
disease fighting benefits
and they found that when you consume it
with black pepper or piperine the
compound in it
it increased the absorption by 154
percent so the medical community like
sort of applauded themselves saying we
had this medical breakthrough we found
that when this happens here's the thing
there's a recipe in ayurveda
and this was also used in ancient asian
medicine and in middle eastern medicine
around the times of the bible
but there was an ancient recipe and it
was a blend of turmeric along with black
pepper ginger
and another warming spice and then gear
coconut it was called turmeric golden
milk or
golden tea that recipe has been around
for 3000 years
where they knew that back then it's like
so
cheap exactly was it hypocrites in a in
a
in a jail cell talking about how health
begins in your gut right that's right
and it took us
now we're so excited about we discovered
that that's right it's exciting right
it's awesome stuff
all right so i know the next
question for the um some of our internet
warriors will be
these specialized diets the last hundred
years especially last 25 years have
turned into
these almost religious cult like
followings yeah
what happened how did we get here so
these they are wars man
yes so so here's here's essentia what's
happened and you'll get this john it's
we have number one here's here's the
first thing to realize everyone is
very unique individual i mean god has
made everybody unique
in their gifts and their skills even the
way their body works and functions
and ancient like asian medicine for
instance they put people in five types
so it's kind of like the enneagram
or disc profile or myers-briggs they
actually would say okay
you have certain emotions and your body
is built a certain way there are certain
foods that are better for creating
balance in your body
in ancient times they never treated a a
labeled disease they said
you've got this imbalance where your
body's too hot or too cold internally
it's too damp or too dry
we've got to balance these things for
instance why do we call it a cold today
because with a cold it comes from
ancient asian medicine it's
your body is cold internally so you
people tend to take
warming spices to warm their body that's
why it's always like
oregano ginger cayenne these kind you
know like these
warming herbs and this little hot
toddies our grandparents used to do that
was so funny so here's the thing whiskey
and again we're not here promoting
everybody drink whiskey but
it's the hottest of all the cores it's
the most warming if anybody's ever had
they'll warm your insides
it's actually so it's much better than
something like a beer which is cooling
all that being said so it's all about
bringing balance to the body to the
unique individual
so for some people keto diet is great
for probably about 20
25 of the population for a period of
time like maybe 30 days okay
but for a lot of people it's a terrible
diet and what happens is
somebody will say oh i followed keto or
i followed paleo or i was a vegan
and it radically changed my health and
it's great for that person but i'd ask
everybody listening here
have you ever had a friend follow a diet
and it was not like a miracle for them
and then you tried the same thing it
didn't work for you exactly and that's
because
you're a unique individual and i'll give
you an example if somebody has
inflammatory bowel disease
they should not have they should have
zero raw vegetables it should all be
cooked vegetables bone broth like that
sort of thing but if somebody has liver
disease or cancer they do good with a
lot of raw foods and vegetable juices
so i mean really what you know
ann wigmore said one man's food is
another man's poison and vice versa so
it's important to understand you're a
unique individual you really need to
find what works for you so unfortunately
but but yes there have become these
cult-like followings of certain diets
and and to their uh you know
it has worked for them but it definitely
doesn't work for everybody
and we've talked about this on this show
is if we step back 100 200 years we've
had this cultural obsession with shoving
everything into a bell curve that's
right what's the thing that works for
everybody
and because we can sell it to everybody
yup and so we stamped this imaginary
food pyramid this is how we should all
do it and it's going to work right
and it's it can feel untethering to
think oh gosh then what is the thing
and that's where you get walk alongside
a good practitioner and you
learn to listen to your body and this
works and this doesn't and
and then now i mean my wife she's she's
one that can handle
high high carbohydrate intake yeah i'm
so jealous
and i'm somebody who can handle very
little and we both meet
and we figured out how to have great
family meals right and she doesn't get
her feelings hurt i don't get my
feelings to her
our kids so it's it's in the middle
there
how do you you've been in this space a
long time how do you deal with
um people come after you right there's a
lot of chris
and it's not criticism like hey we don't
we disagree with you the criticism is
you're hurting people
like you're crazy what are you doing
right how do you deal with that man
yeah so you know for me and what's funny
is i i don't i don't read a lot of those
comments now i want to be aware i want
to be responsible but for me i just i
anchor into these core principles and a
lot of them start in the bible these
health and biblical principles
and then they really go off as well to
you know these ancient things that i
think have been proven for again as i
mentioned
thousands of years now and then in
running a practice myself so
for me i guess i combat it with this
i'll give an example if somebody would
say
dr axe when you speak out or tell people
that
their first line of defense should be
nutrition and mindset and relationships
and all of those sort of these lifestyle
factors
and people should focus on those even
before they would go and take
pop a pill hey that's that's hurting
people we really believe that today's
medical system is the way that things
should be done and so
i've heard that plenty but anybody says
that anymore but
i know i got you i literally had
somebody the other day
stop me and say you're hurting people
with all your false information out
there just a random person on the street
awesome but then i'm at whole foods and
i have all my old patients coming up to
me and stopping and saying oh dr
axe like hey i actually had a woman come
up pretty recently and she
she had lost 80 pounds her husband had
lost 120 pounds
and he was a former nfl offensive
lineman so i mean he just
you know he he he lost way to transform
himself so i have so many thousands of
people that have shared with me
their their health transformation
reversing diabetes
overcoming hypothyroidism fertility you
know so many women who now have been
able to have kids following some of this
information
so so for me i really just fill up on
those things and you're gonna have
haters you're gonna have doubters
but at this point i don't know i've got
pretty thick i've got pretty thick skin
i think if you just focus on those
things and focus on your mission and
vision
that really helps too because for me
saving people saving the world with
super food knowing i've got to heal you
know i want to help heal the planet i
want to help people
and knowing all these positive results
we've seen kind of it kind of is like a
i don't know it's more like i have a nat
around me now it doesn't really didn't
get you
yeah so i'm gonna speak my life into
yours and you may say that i don't have
that at all
i'm similar there and for a season
minute i wouldn't sleep at night like
someone would write something mean
especially when i was working with with
college students or with police officers
i was i was doing stuff after hours say
hey
terribly and man that wiped me out now
i've
i've got people that i can call if i get
stuck and
um i'm i'm more like you my skin's got a
lot thicker
my wife's hasn't right and so when
someone's ugly
she's ready to go to war oh man and so
you're married
um how do you manage that
that like the most important
relationship to you and and she
i know she has a tendency to go to war
on your behalf but how do you
how do you manage that criticism being
counter-cultural
saying hey i'm cool but also man you
love this person who really loves you
yeah you may say she doesn't do that at
all but no she does see i'm that's why
i'm laughing so
my my wife is uh and let me say this too
my wife's also a physician
okay so she went to chiropractic college
she got training and like functional
uh uh nutrition and an exercise and
she's a yoga instructor so she has a lot
of credentials herself
and she's just an amazing strong
christian principled woman
and so for that she's there but she is
my biggest defender
okay and if you want to get her fired up
it's you know
come after me or our family and so there
are occasions where i'm like
hey we're good yeah we're good hey just
you know
um but but yeah i mean she's definitely
my biggest offender and that's i mean
what a blessing you know to be an
embarrassed to wear
and i know you feel the same way it's
like maybe when you have a spouse who is
for you yeah you know like that it's uh
but but it absolutely bothers her more
than it bothers me absolutely and i
think it would be the same thing if
somebody
if somebody says something negative
about chelsea
my wife oh dude it's on i'm definitely
again it's
10x how i feel about it somebody says
about me okay so flip that around
another thing i just want to imagine too
i was joking around this i
one of two of our best friends they have
a daughter we have a one-year-old they
have a one and a half year old
and we're joking around the other day so
like our daughter now she's waving to
people
and like if somebody doesn't wave back
actually i get i'm like
god like you know anyways
yeah if they somebody rolls their eyes
at them at a restaurant
it's like dude we can go in the parking
lot it's for no reason right
and my kids being annoying too by the
way um but yeah i'm the same way
so let's flip that around a little bit
um
i think one of the challenges i've
experienced
is we have a bunch of credentialed
people speaking into the world
with a lot of different platforms and a
lot of different motivations
one is i really i saw my mom suffer and
i don't want anyone to do that
i'm gonna go down a rabbit hole to
figure out what happened and then
oh my gosh i've got my own patience i
want to help heal the planet and this
stuff's all
interconnected whatever that looks like
yep then you get other folks who just
want to sell a book or just want to make
some money et cetera
one of the biggest challenges i'm
looking at seeing is
people's inability to say hey i really
really believed in that i was wrong
and one of the cool so i was an academic
nerd before i came here
and i saw um i saw it happen with covet
in a pretty unique way
i knew from my researcher friends that
when somebody lays down a hey we think
11 million people are gonna die
in the in the for scientists their job
is to be less wrong
and so they immediately go cool we're on
and so then
a few weeks later another group another
college group says hey
only six million are going to die and
okay we got a new model we'll put it on
this
and the whole art of science is being
less wrong then the two
groups that can't say that word are
politicians and media people
and if a scientist has rolled himself up
into a media world then they get locked
into
i can't say i was wrong on something one
of the first people to tell me i'm wrong
is often my wife is a is a phd
researcher too
it's her to say john you are way off on
what are you talking about
have you had something that you were
dead set on and suddenly you've been
like
oh i wasn't right on that i've even had
to come on this show i've called
somebody back
and said i gave you wrong advice man i
should have told you something else
you know so i'll share a couple things
early on in my career
i really felt like the more plants the
better in terms of raw
and i was sharing that earlier and i had
to learn through clinical experiences
that
a raw like like for instance a salad
most people think
a salad is good for everybody so even my
clinic first year i taught some raw food
classes and all these things and then i
was started working with people with
crohn's and ulcerative colitis and ibs
and started noticing wow this is not
working for these people diverticulitis
some others
and and i had to go learn you know and
so and so i was abs
that's just an example of my nutritional
philosophy
being wrong and that really led me to
really continuing to study more of
of what i study now and there there's
been you know
i almost always listen to chelsea but i
mean
anytime i don't listen to my wife i'm it
is wrong i mean i can tell you it's like
10 out of 10. 10 out of 10. it's 100 out
of 100 for me there you go